for et social study catching you up on
what stars are posting online really Wow
okay
JLo flashes some major underboob as she
prepares for her upcoming show the
singer Instagram this sexy rehearsal
shot smoldering in a tank top and pants
caption getting this mind and body right
for Vegas and get up everyday wake up
kick-ass repeat next up Demi Lovato
travels to Dubai the confident singer
posted cute pigs from her trip abroad
she's all smiles with her crew riding
camels in the desert moving on Saturday
Night Live shared this behind-the-scenes
photo of Kristen Stewart ahead of her
hosting debut this weekend hi I'm
Kristen Stewart and I'm hosting SNL with
musical guest Alessia Cara man this is
gonna be so fun you excited yeah I am
this is this is me maybe we don't have
to work on that and each elbow gets
dating advice from adorable kids while
searching for a Valentine can someone
tell me what happens in a date you take
the girl somewhere nice like so much she
likes like a girl concert okay pay for
everything and you agree with everything
she says it doesn't matter about you and
that's about the girl
[Music]